still standing strong but how do you
capture the life of a musical superstar
whose careers stretches back to the 70s
Sir Elton was a little bit funny about
doing TV interviews so instead he was
driven down through the crowds
preferring to let his film do the
talking Rocket Man isn't just a story of
how Sir Elton became one of our biggest
musical exports it sets out to be a
frank take on the addictions that
haunted him and unlike typical biopics
it's told there's a musical for Taron
Egerton it meant shaving his hairline
and learning the piano for the road it
never felt like hard work it just felt
like an extraordinary privilege he is
the most fun
naughty irreverent kind brilliant man
with sorrell turn outspoken on the issue
of gay rights and bringing to life his
story filmmakers have had to field
questions throughout about how gay the
film would be if sex scenes would be
censored whether straight actors should
be playing gay roles hours we should be
the best dad for the role and I don't
think someone's personal I should really
have an effect on what jobs the counter
can take
[Music]
if director Dexter Fletcher's name is
familiar that's because he's the man
that stepped into the breach when the
filmmaker behind the hugely popular rock
biopic Bohemian Rhapsody was fired
comparisons between the two films have
been inevitable but while some critics
accused the Freddie Mercury film of
glossing over his love life Rocket Man
hasn't shied away from painting an
accurate picture of sir Elton's
sexuality including his relationship
with former lover and manager John Reed
these are certain aspects of his life
there are just a given you know helping
his guy he's proud of that he's married
his husband and kids and there's nothing
to really hide there and so it's a
seminal moment in anyone's life I think
when you have that first intimate moment
that first kiss and and as a young man I
wanted to explore that and look at you
know that relationship in the film